now then imagine spending nearly 30
years on death row for a crime he didn't
commit well at nightmare was answer near
a Hinton's reality wrongfully convicted
over the murders of two people back in
1985 justice was finally delivered in
2015 when the American Supreme Court
overturned his conviction on appeal and
since then mr. Hinton has written his
memoir the Sun does shine how I find
life on death row well I spoke to him
earlier this afternoon from Birmingham
Alabama and started by asking him how he
could have been convicted on such
unreliable evidence in America if you
don't have the money to hide decent
defense you will be convicted in America
with no doubt and so it don't have to be
born African America in Alabama along
with not having the funds to hire a
decent attorney and so the prosecution
knew that he could get a conviction
because of those two things being born
black and not having the Florence too
high he a qualified our attorney and
there was no evidence to convict me just
the fact that I had off state appointed
attorney who did just enough to get me
convicted and I spent the next 30 years
on Alabama death row for a crime that
the state of Alabama knew that I didn't
commit and Ray just outlined for us how
little evidence there was the fact that
you were working 15 miles away whether
very solid alibi 50 miles away from the
scene of the crime
the forensic and ballistic evidence
didn't prove anything whatsoever just
just talk us through those details well
you know I was cutting grass or in the
backyard and these two detectives showed
up and said they had a warrant for my
arrest and I asked him for what and they
wouldn't tell him at the time but
skipping forward so they acts mean that
I have a only firearm and I said no I do
not I said but my mother having old
smiston Weston
thirty-eight and they went back and
asked my mother to let him see it I
wanna do the detective she said said
there was nothing but dust on it the gun
hadn't been fired in over 25 years or
they took this gun and said that it
match the bullets that they got out of
the deceased body I knew that was a lie
because they're good as I said it hadn't
been fired in over 25 years
then they charged me later with capital
murder ah they got to understand and say
that the bullets are match as I said the
victim and so I was sentenced to death
for crime they knew that I didn't commit
they knew that the gun didn't match and
it took off eji Brian Stevenson over 16
years to prove on my innocent wasn't it
the case of when you were arrested a
white officer said well I believe you
are innocent but you're gonna go to jail
anyway yes we was in the car and he said
there's five things they're going to
convict you and I said what are those
and he said number one you're black
number two a white man is gonna say you
shot him whether you shot him or not I
don't care he said believe me I don't
care he said number three you're gonna
have a white prosecutor no before you're
gonna have a white judge and number five
you're gonna have an all-white jury and
he said do you know what that's spelled
and he repeated the word conviction five
times and so those are the things that
are actually convicting me but why we
was in the police station accident
attorney I mean this detector I said
detective or why are you doing this to
me I haven't killed anyone and I was
trying to convince this detective that
you got the wrong person and he looked
at me and he said let me be honest with
you I truly believe you didn't do it he
said but y'all and y'all was referring
to all African America and Ray I know
you're a religious man
let me ask you about forgiveness have
you forgiven those that's saw you
convicted were prepared to see you die
on death row and then those individuals
that collaborated to keep you in prison
an innocent man for 30 years yes you
know I opted I'm going to be honest with
you I woke up one morning after hearing
a grown man cry and that had lost his
mother and I looked in the mirror and I
didn't like the person that I was had
become I've always been a person who
loved his smile laughing I love to make
other people laugh and smile because I
truly believe that laughter is good for
the soul and I sit there on this bed
that was too small for me in our extra
guard that I believed in to remove this
hatred that I had for these men that had
did this to me and eventually I began to
smile again to laugh again and try to
make other people laugh as well and I
realized that by forgiving them I could
truly live and as you noticed on my book
it's how I found life and freedom on
death row oh I could not do a thing
about the 30 years of the fall silk use
but I knew that I could not allow these
men to steal my joy any longer I wanted
to take my life back
and so by forgiving them I truly believe
that none of us will ever be free until
you for yield and I want your audience
to know that forgiveness is not about to
the other person forgiveness is about
you and so I had no choice but to
forgive him in order for me to live in
order for me to enjoy life to enjoy it
without even thinking about them I had
to forgive them and I forgave them and I
just lived the best life that I could